hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
before Al Gore's Inconvenient Truth
there was Ted Turner's inconvenient
cartoon series known as Captain Planet
and the Planeteers god shoot me this
environmental pitch it was designed to
make kids more aware of the environment
and tell them all the things that they
can do to save the environment but most
likely won't this show was awful and I
mean awful nobody liked it nobody
listened to what I had to say so why do
we keep watching it I mean this show was
on for four seasons that's a pretty long
time bye kids show standards so why
don't we keep watching this shit if it
was so bad honestly because there was
nothing else that was on in this
timeslot I think the only other thing
that was on with Beakman's world and God
knows how much I don't want to be
willingly educated by a Brooklyn
scientist and a giant rat he's an
exterminator his nightmare so we kept
watching Captain Planet much to our
everlasting shame now for those of you
who don't know the infamous story of
Captain Planet consider yourselves very
fortunate but he'll I'm gonna let Geordi
from Star Trek tell you anyway our world
is in peril Gaia the Spirit of the earth
can no longer stand the terrible
destruction plaguing our planet
five magic rings - five special youngbae
five powers combined they've summoned
Birds greatest champion Captain Planet
well that's the cliff note version
anyway the whole story starts when the
Earth Spirit Gaia is awakened from our
earthly slumber is it me or does it look
like she's always in a perfume
commercial
after she wakes up she sees those poor
silly humans who are destroying the
earth it was poor silly humans again so
she sends out five magic rings to five
teenagers
Kwami from Africa ghee from Asia linka
from the Soviet Union mighty from South
America and wheeler from North America
wheeler wheeler some parent was actually
cruel enough to name their kid wheeler
the only wheelers I know about are the
wheelers from Return to Oz and the
further I stay away from the end of that
you know this has been a very weird day
one minute I'm a kid from Brooklyn the
next minute I'm some sort of cut-rate
superhero oh I think I'm gonna hate
wheeler I mean the other characters are
passable but this guy is just obnoxious
what's it supposed to mean it's like if
Tony Danza got kicked in the nuts and
was looking around for the guy who did
it
hey yo who kicked me in the nuts each of
them are given a magic ring that
controls one of the Earth's elements
like earth wind water and fire
oh I see every time wheeler says fire a
giant flaming fireball pops doubt man
how lame is that
that's like me getting in the head with
a ruler every time I say what'd I get
hit in the head with a ruler every time
a chicken okay
guess I'm not gonna say ruler but what
about my tea what's his magic power nine
is hard
since you are heart heart
they get fire wind and water I get
fucking heart
what are they bought well why can't I
get a the flashy powers and stuff into a
heart are you kidding me but fucking
cool I mean he can't do anything with
heart but you make people feel better
who gives a shit I mean this kid totally
got ripped off I mean how do you think
he feels about this whole thing
I recently sat down with my tea this
past week to find out just how he felt
about this situation I'll tell you how I
feel about the whole situation
I'm fucking pissed off man you know hey
what kind of kid wants to have heart as
a power I mean I can't believe it Jesus
yeah but surely there must have been
some good came out of this after all
we're bringing people together fat
people bringing people together doesn't
help you sell toys it just makes you a
pussy a pussy I am a pussy well why do
you think you got heart and everyone
else got the flash your powers because
I'm Indian it's all Ted Turner's plan to
keep the Indian man down fucking
cocksucker
wait a minute I thought you were from
South America what's this crap about you
being in here you're not the real Matty
are you the thing about that is a heart
oh fuck it in here
I am nothing but trouble I mean how is
heart even supposed to work you just say
heart and all of a sudden people feel
better give me a break
I mean look at this thing are you
telling me that this little thing is
actually supposed to make people feel
better
wrong way all right here is this is the
ring that's supposed to make everybody
feel hunky-dory oh wow entrance this is
kind of nice I feel so relaxed and
pleasant so what if I don't have fire
wind or water it's not like I have to be
ruler of the earth direct alright so you
get the idea about the Rings and
everything but where does Captain Planet
come in well and they do combine their
powers together they unleash Captain
Planet who kind of looks like silver
surfers gay brother who has a summer
home in Malibu oh yes I better make like
the wind and blow captain planets main
job is to save the earth while also
making as many horrible puns as possible
and now I'm gonna rain on your parade
it's time to tie up this person you know
smokings back to your house
nothing like a wild ride
get rid of an old flame
to branch out I'm feeling fine how about
you ah
it's worse than I thought I know what
you're saying yourself please tell me
that there's something that can kill him
well thank heavenly God there is Captain
Planet only weakness is you guessed it
pollution he droughts him in oil smoke
or toxic waste and he goes down like a
government bill to save the rainforest
the only way to save him is to clean him
off so he can regenerate from the Sun oh
right he's a solar-powered Captain
Planet you know they always sound great
until the payment plans come in we'll
see about that
seriously though how hard is it just to
throw toxins on a person
this shit's easier to find the
kryptonite you might be asking yourself
what kind of villains does Captain plan
to fight anyway well of course it's
rotten billionaire tycoons who want to
do nothing but pollute the world all
except Ted Turner of course he is Jesus
and of course they all have those
traditional cosmopolitan names like
hoggish greedly verminous come and slice
lunch seriously would you ever do
business with a person named splice
sludge it's like marrying a woman named
nasty Mick spends money it just says bad
news written all over it
please God the other strange thing about
these films is that a lot of them
actually have celebrity voices like John
Ratzenberger Martin Sheen Jeff Goldblum
Tim Curry and even meg Ryan how the fuck
did they get meg Ryan did she own back
taxes or something honey it makes no
sense well it's even stranger than that
is that they actually make the villains
look a lot like the celebrities
themselves like Meg Ryan's yellow hair
Tim Curry sunken-in eyes and the less I
say about Jeff Goldblum the better and
that's also Whoopi Goldberg as the Earth
Spirit Gaia now here's what I don't
understand if she's supposed to be the
most powerful essence of the earth why
doesn't she just stopped these polluting
a-holes herself
don't worry
I will be with you the spirit o spirit
mm-hmm you know from my past experience
spirit has usually meant a coward
chicken pansy who doesn't want to get
hurt and would rather sacrifice the
lives of teenagers so that she doesn't
miss her favorite reruns of Gilligan but
hey that's just my past experience gee I
didn't think of that
you may also notice that anytime there's
trouble it's Kwame who initiates calling
Captain Planet let our powers combined
powers combine let our powers combined
why does he get to call the shot I mean
that's a lot of power can you imagine if
he didn't want to say those words Oh a
man we're in a tight Jam uh Kwame
don't you have something to say I'm not
going to say it not until you apologize
for sniffing me on the bill at Olive
Garden oh come on man I was short on
cash and I look like dumb fucking King
diva
all right I'm sorry then let our powers
combine douche what nothin weird
most of these episodes follow the same
pattern some evildoer is polluting the
earth for the sole purpose of being a
douche the kids come to help can't quite
handle it so they callin Captain Planet
to save the day but not all these
episodes just focus on the environment
there's actually one or two episodes
that handle different subject matters so
Captain Planet what other issues are you
gonna talk to grade school kids about
eight you tested positive for the HIV
virus
since beer and panic all right so
captain plan is going to talk about AIDS
god help us
so apparently verminous gum has an evil
plan to make high schoolers really hate
this one kid who happens to have AIDS
just listen to his foolproof evil plot
once we let people know the kid has AIDS
we can panic all down see when people
panic they don't put if they don't think
they stay stupid about AIDS and it's
forever
makes sense to me there are only a few
ways to contract the virus using drugs
with needles unprotected sex or he could
have gotten it from that blood
transfusion he had a few years back
don't talk about drugs or unprotected
sex with miles long with you who cares
how I got it it sticks there you have it
folks the understatement of the century
AIDS stinks and here's another thing I
just found out Hitler was a dork
naturally the kids coach comes in to try
to give him some advice
you wanna talk nothing to say it's all
over not the way I hear it coach I've
got AIDS wrong you're HIV positive big
difference they probably won't even let
me play in the big game
wrong again Andrews you're gonna be
played in that game and anybody who says
otherwise I'll have to deal with me whoa
coach's a bit of a psycho soon verminous
start spreading rumors and lies about
AIDS did you hear about Todd Andrews Shh
he's a closeted mumbler soon everybody
even the adults are calling for the
hanging of this kid with AIDS if only
they knew then environmentally aware
children's cartoon could show them the
error of their ways
of course captain PSA comes along to
help set the record straight to the
people I think these people need a
little education about the HIV virus may
I have your attention please this is
gonna be painful a lot of you are
worried about AIDS give them the facts
coach you can't get aids from casual
contact you've been led astray by lies
Todd hasn't changed that's right
he's the same kid who played his heart
out for you right here on this court
last week deal with the real people get
the facts the power is yours and this
Beach is terrible troll what are you
gonna do turn your back on him or give
him the chance he deserves
this is like the most easily led crowd
in the world hey everybody
childbirth is bad but genocide is good
another issue that's kind of hard to see
Captain Planet account is gang violence
you heard right gang violence just
listen to some of the streetwise back
talk we doin here pretty kid
don't sweat it don't we hitting the spot
to score some get they can't do its
r.i.p time for you yo yo I'm gonna bust
the wicked on Pookie in the back of your
behind mildly annoying acquaintance and
the way they conveyed the terror of gang
violence is by having pictures of civil
rights leaders posted all throughout the
cartoon they never really referenced
them they just kind of put them there I
mean look at this they don't say
anything they don't do anything they
just kind of appear and then disappear
um deep gee I hope there's some retarded
teenagers and flying blue man and gate
on the way that can sum this all up
can't you see it's time to stop wrecking
and start really educating peace or war
it's your choice that would have been
the funny ending but instead we get a
look into the gang members heads as they
analyze all that the civil rights
leaders have fought for I guess this has
good intentions but some of these images
get pretty damn graphic stop
and you got to get so wide present else
taxi but uh kids you might want to
switch it over to Sesame Street right
now these people don't know what they're
doing so much for drama and of course at
the end of every episode we had to
listen to that god-awful song that we
all hated to listen to and yet we could
never get out of our heads well there
was that one guy who always summed up my
feelings towards the show at the end all
right ed Turner you made your point and
we'll make a deal with you we'll start
cleaning up the planet and you stop
making these god-awful cartoons that way
the planet can be nice and clean so that
you can become supreme ruler god dammit
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to ruler ha I really
hate this episode